Good afternoon everyone, the first thing
I would like to say is that we are very sorry for the
inconveniences that Argentines have been
suffering since 7 in the morning due to a
lack of electricity.
Carlos
García Pereira, who is the
General Director of Transener, and Jorge Ruiz Soto are accompanying me at this conference.
who is the deputy general manager of camesa
what we know at this time is that
at 70 7 in the morning today there was
a failure in the coastal transportation system
failures that occur
frequently
[Music]
in both the Argentine system
and in  any system in another country
that failure is not something abnormal or
extraordinary what is something abnormal
or extraordinary and should not happen is the
chain of subsequent events
that caused the total disconnection I think
it is worth clarifying that this
total disconnection occurs in a way
Automatically, it is the computers that
govern the system that do so when they
detect imbalances that could
cause major damage.  or and in milliseconds
the system is disconnected to protect it
takes out there was no alert there is no
possibility that there is any alert
because it is something that the human brain
could not detect there is no human intervention
we do not have more information at this
time about why it happened it existed in  the
regulatory framework a
failure analysis protocol for which the
companies have to submit a report
on what was happening and what happened
at that time based on those reports
camesa, which is the one that dispatches
the electricity  the
pertinent analysis and there we will know
why this extraordinary event occurred
that should not happen and
should not happen again,
the necessary measures will be taken once we
know what happened and also the
system and the regulatory framework provides
sanctions for the  in case there is
someone responsible for what has happened and those sanctions are applied by both the insider and the secret can be applied  energy
at this moment and since 7 in the
morning what we are concentrating on is
the recovery of the system at this
moment before entering I asked what
state we were in since 707 we have been
recovering the system at this precise
moment we are with 56 percent  percent
of the country reconnected with 56
percent of the demand that was being
met again as
the day progresses this percentage will
continue to grow until it reaches one hundred
percent
and I repeat that we are very sorry for the
inconvenience this is causing to
all families the
electricity supply is a fundamental thing today
for everyone's life and it has been
corrected throughout the day as I was
saying and we hope that this continues to
happen in the remaining hours
we are open to questions
good afternoon ossuary coordinator of the
agency bloomberg wanted to ask you
what options that variants ending
as the causes of false sits
consider  I am within the causes the
possibility of a cyberattack and what
probability is assigned and
secondly what are the times they have
to find the cause of the failure in
what period could we expect that
response thank you very much
at this moment we do not rule out any
possibility but we  I would say that we are
not, we do not believe
that the cyberattack is not among the
primary alternatives that are being
considered, but it would be hasty on my
part to be able to tell you
today how long the report may be,
I would ask for the shirt,
more or less, in how long do you think we
will be able to  find out what happened
response time
fifth market players will give
the result in principle they are
first
within 48
and then there is a week ten days
to fully analyze all the
reports we receive are received in
shirt and have a final report
and when we have it, we will
make it known and, as I said before,
the pertinent measures will be taken first to  to see
what happened so that it does not happen again
and secondly so that the
corresponding sanctions are applied and that
are foreseen in the regulatory framework,
the Catalan celestial secretary or
infobae wanted to ask him beyond
the data that the president himself gave,
what had been the  your communication
with the president throughout this
morning about how you were informing him of all
this we have been in contact
since 7:07 in the morning on many
occasions you have just spoken with him he is
following minute by minute what is
happening and  the same with respect to the
transener table and the entire
Argentine electricity system, which is a
very robust system today, that is, this is an
extraordinary event that should not have
occurred in any way beyond the fact
that there have been similar events in
other countries on  The Argentine system today is
a very robust system with excess capacity for
both generation and
transport, which is something I
repeat  there are no reasons why it has
happened but the reality is that it happened
and it is something very serious we cannot leave the
country without electricity from one moment to the
next we are prepared for that not to
be the case so we have to go to
the end to understand
what  happened and to punish those who
have been responsible for not having
fulfilled some of their
responsibilities but I repeat that we
will know within 15 days we must be
responsible and not say anything until we
have the entire succession of
events
detailed
I am Martin  from the clarion air,
secretary, you just said, well, here is
a chain of events that
led to this, how many errors are there in
that chain of events from the time it
is cut,
from the time the power lines are cut, until
then all the power plants are cut, well,
how many concatenated errors there  It
is not what I would tell you that today we do not know what
it is what I said before is since the
system is destabilized by this failure
in e  The transport system, which is a
simple fault, since the system is
destabilized until it is cut off, milliseconds pass,
that is, it is the
protection systems that produce the total disconnection,
what must be understood is why it happened
because that fault was not isolated, what
were the  previous circumstances we
were working in the range that marks
the norm
as I said before we have
surplus generation capacity with
which I can answer you now and that
we will reveal the conclusions of the report
when they are ready but today it
would still be risky to talk about errors
to your  right, everything in your morality of television chronicle
there you listen to me
the question is if the government through
its word rules out if one could have
been a sabotage and what happened here
because it was historic the first time it
happens at the country level the
sister countries were affected and  uruguay on brazil
and if so, if the government
on your behalf is going to carry out
any  type of complaint regarding
this cost that the government is paying
for, for which it paid a historical record, if I
repeat to you that today we are focused at
this moment on recovering the service
for all Argentines as quickly as
possible and this investigation process is going to begin
it will take time
companies do not have to present their
reports or we rule out nothing but
before venturing into what
will happen next it is preferable to know in
technical detail what
happened in a system that is prepared
to support a much larger generation
we are in a moment
low demand low demand because it
is a low demand Sunday because
we are at a time of year when it
is neither hot nor cold, so
we are at a time when the reserve
of the Argentine generation system, which
today is around 11 percent  cent
measure on the peak day which is in the
summer the hottest days today in the
morning at the time the
reaction occurred  serva of the system was greater than 20
percent, that is,
what has happened is very extraordinary,
that is why it is the first time that it has happened
in Argentina, as you said, but
it seems to me that it is much more prudent not to
venture into any hypothesis and to
continue working as  We have been doing it
since 707 so that all
Argentine households have electricity again.
Good afternoon, Mariana. Security of all.
Good news. Ask her basically about the
structure of the system, which has remained
as a generalized idea that something,
a failure of some characteristics, may
be able to cut  a system of
milliseconds speaks of a fragile system
beyond the robust one that you spoke of
because of an idea of well, something happens and an entire count
y runs out of energy except for Tierr
del Fuego, which is not connected to th
national system, precisely if that makes
you rethink  in the
country's energy system and it really is so robust and on the
other hand ask him how much he thinks he
can get  To delay the
total reconnection of homes,
first I would tell you that more than the
fragility when you refer to the
cut in milliseconds and precisely
to protect the system
because they are technical systems that can
fail and if there were no such firewalls
there could be a  greater damage with
which I am going to ask
the general director of transener to
technically add his opinion on the
question that is how you asked it,
we have recovered 57 percent
from 7 in the morning to 3:30,
we think that the rate of  recovery is
going to continue accelerating with which
we hope that in the next few hours
that percentage will be greater each time, that is, at
this very moment that we are talking about
probably already the recovery the
recovery
that percentage will be greater but you could
expand a little in terms of
fragility  o robustness of the
argentine system the argentine system is
highly robust has a strong level
of investment plenty of power as d  The
secretary of government said about the
transport system, especially for a day
like today at the time that it was a
very low demand
, which I know in order to give
the system that robustness enough to
work in more complex situations of
high demand  system 2 has a
number of automatisms called
automatic
generation and demand disconnection systems that are
linked to communications systems
that take information from all the
power plants and all the
transformer stations that make up the sar and
all of this is processed in a system  very
complex and if in that system some
element for some reason that we still do not
know did not act correctly, it
can produce a situation like that, that is
why we do it here, we
visualize more a process of a
technical problem than any other
element such as being a cyberattack  or
sabotage we do not rule it out because in
this instance all hypotheses must be considered.
esis
for us it is essential to determine
determine is not something that one looks at a
screen and already has expenses we have to
process thousands and thousands of information
that are recorded and this is another
important piece of information that is the information of
how origin or ruiz soto said in 48 hours
It is not that the company is going to deliver a
report saying what it thinks, everything
is recorded in real time, the
information that we have from Transener,
these shirts are also registered, there are
two routes of information in
real time and through two different communication processes
as to give  veracity of the
information and this is available to
all authorities now in
such complex systems of this type a failure
can occur
the truth we have to determine it
would not be serious on our part to say something happened to
put it we have perfectly
determined we are interested in avoiding
this we really believe that the system
is robust enough that it
has a capacity  It is really important
that investments are being made in
the different really
important sectors that we accompany each other
within our
disposition for protection
and I give
indications signals positions and not
only say is this or is it this
we have to analyze what happened in the
whole  come up with a theory and that is the
information that is going to be delivered to
camesa and to the national regulatory entity such as
the position of what happened in the
transport system,
I insist, it was not subject to rigorous conditions, on
the contrary, it was a
time of low demand where the
The transmission was perfect and that fault
that occurs permanently had to
have been cleared by the
control center operator, the line had to have been
tested, which he did, and the service had
to have entered again, if there was
a fault with permanent characteristics, it
simply goes back for
protection.  the demilitarization remains outside the reason
why it was extended to the extent that it was
extended  It is precisely what we have
to analyze with depth and
knowledge and age,
that is why a little more hours are still required
to have that report
in ink from the agency
télam I speak that at 3:30 p.m. there was 56
percent of the park recovered
wanted  to know if they have any estimates
of when they can have
100% of the park
if at this moment it would be risky to
tell you an hour in which we are going to be able to
have 100% of the country reconnected
what we are seeing is that
every hour we are  raising that level
and working on the
total recovery of the system I cannot tell
you by giving you an exact forecast because today
we do not have it, it is working here for a month to
transfer all the generators,
each one from its place and every hour
we are raising that percentage, let's hope
get to 100 percent as soon as
possible
the last question
the nation's secretary sofia diamond
to ask why land the
fire was not affected by the  blackout and
what relationship that why it happens with
uruguay uruguay was also
affected and what explanation did the
country give if Tierra del Fuego can
I explain it to you why Tierra del Fuego is the
only part of the country that is not part
of the national interconnection system
So that car contained
with respect to Uruguay, I ask you
also,
Uruguay is affected and we are mutually
affected with Uruguay with two
men and the
Uruguayan system or the Argentine system have to fail because
we are interconnected through a
big jump, that is, there are two
interconnections  very very important the
networks of 500 of the transener borders with
those of gustas in uruguay the disturbance
was precisely in the bell zone
coloniality that the center of the river was
very close to the link it has
with uruguay with which I also
visualize the disturbance and  it also
forced Uruguay to disconnect, and
logically it was in an
easier position to recompose because it isolated  its
system and was recomposed from the
hydraulic generation that it has
was also altered in part of the south of
Brazil due to the same circumstances and,
as the secretary of government said,
Argentina was linked to Brazil,
receiving energy from Brazil because
Brazil currently has a surplus
of hydraulic energies and by agreements
that exist between the two countries,
these energies are used in order to
prevent that water from being discharged
and lost, so it is received
later and compensated at the time that Brazil
also needs it for that reason the
two felt the disturbance
Basically, this is not different from what
happens when an earthquake occurs, where it occurs in
one country, but the neighboring country also perceives it
in the electrical system, more or
less, so that something more
or less of that energy that we were
receiving from  brazil today was in
compensation for exports that
we made during the summer to brazil
thanks to you